so as we get into our lead up for DC's
darkside war what I want to do here is
have a discussion on the origin of the
anti-monitor as well as where he stands
in terms of DC's continuity and the
reason why is that there seems to be a
bit of confusion regarding the
anti-monitor in terms of how it was
depicted in crisis on Infinite Earths
and the version that we see now with
Jeff Jones run on the Justice League and
so the anti-monitor was really created
as a plot device more than anything else
so the reason why is because when DC
launched the crisis on Infinite Earths
event in 1985 in order to reset their
continuity they needed something to kick
everything off more so than that they
needed an explanation for why the
multiverse was coming to an end because
a DC Multiverse had been created as a
way to explain the varying differences
between characters like Superman in the
1940s versus 1950s as well as why it was
a Barry Allen and Hal Jordan had
replaced Jay Garrick and Allen Scott as
a flash and Green Lantern respectively
by the time 1985 came around the entire
history of DC was swimming and
continuity issues and had largely turned
into a massive confusing mess in order
to rectify this problem under Marv
Wolfman DC launched the crisis on
Infinite Earths and effectively
eliminated 50 years worth of history and
12 issues in this story the origin of
the anti-monitor is given to us in
tandem with the history of the guardians
of the universe but also serves as an in
continuity explanation of how the
multiverse came into existence it
covered in issue number 7 titled beyond
the silent night as we're told
prior to the creation of the Manhunters
and the Green Lantern Corps when the
guardians of the universe were in their
infancy they had existed as a
technologically advanced race called the
Owens at some point along the line one
of their numbers a man named Crona
became obsessed with the origin of the
universe because the Owens were advanced
enough to know that the action of
observing the origin of all things could
result in a change to the present by way
of a ripple effect the use of their
technology for this purpose was
completely outlawed however because
Cronus desire for knowledge outweighed
his concern of the consequences he broke
the sacred laws and in doing so started
a chain reaction that had two
consequences the first was that the
existing universe referred to as Earth
one was replicated several times over
resulting in the formation of the
multiverse and the second was
that the antimatter universe was born
and taking a look at the replication of
realities while DC and marble both use
numerical designations for their
alternate universes
unlike Marvel DC takes a more practical
approach rather than arbitrarily
assigning numbers with no real pattern
DC provides numbers for their most
prominent universes in ascending order
what this meant was that when DC created
the multiverse during the flash of two
worlds story in 1961 and made it a point
to tell us that earth 1 was the Silver
Age universe and then earth to house the
Golden Age universe in terms of the
continuity within the comics DC argued
that the Silver Age universe had always
been there but was it revealed until the
Golden Age had ended and the Silver Age
started now regarding the antimatter
universe much like the Marvel multiverse
and the negative zones and the DC Comics
there are an infinite number of
alternate realities but there's only one
antimatter universe when Crona had
observed the origin of all things and
brought forth the formation of the
multiverse in the antimatter universe
this resulted in the formation of the
monitor on the moon of OA and the
anti-monitor on the planet chord in the
antimatter universe as we're told here
the monitor represents all positive
energy and the multiverse and the
anti-monitor represents all negative
energy in the antimatter universe for
those coming from Marvel Comics the best
way to think about this is that the
monitor is equivalent to Marvel's beyond
or from secret wars and the anti-monitor
would be equivalent to the opposite
version of the Beyonder now in terms of
the crisis on Infinite Earths event the
actions of the anti-monitor were twofold
absorb the energies of planets within
his own antimatter universe in order to
build his power up and the second was to
launch a series of attacks wiping out
various positive realities within the
multiverse the seeking to travel back to
the beginning of creation and eliminate
all positive universes leaving only the
antimatter to survive the story saw the
monitor acting as a guide of sorts
bringing the heroes from the surviving
realities together in an effort to merge
all of their universes into one with the
hope of combining their energies as a
way to destroy the anti-monitor now
where the story saw the death of the
monitor and the eventual death of the
anti-monitor
DC used this as a way to eliminate all
of the realities except for one which
was referred to as new earth and along
the way killed off characters like Barry
Allen too big
for Wally West and rewrote the histories
of their various characters similar to
what was done with the new 52
now with the Dark Side war the
anti-monitor actually gets a bit of a
red car because the anti-monitor was
brought back and Geoff Johns run of the
Green Lantern during the Sinestro Corps
war as well as a bright estate and
blackest night stories and because the
Green Lantern titles maintain their
continuity from crisis on Infinite
Earths up through the new 52 what seems
to be happening here is that geoff johns
is using the Green Lantern continuity as
a way to slip the anti-monitor into the
new 52 Justice League as part of the
Dark Side war while keeping his origin
from the crisis on Infinite Earths
intact
the reason that I say this is that with
Justice League issue number 40 the
anti-monitor is revealed to a bit of
being named mobius with his history
expanded on during his encounter with a
man named Metron and the mobius chair to
sidetrack here for a second the mobius
chair was actually a concept created by
Jack Kirby in 1971 as part of the war
surrounding the new God's something we
discussed in my video aren't Darkseid
while sitting on the Mobius chair Metron
exists as the Kronecker of knowledge of
all things that have ever existed and
that he has ever seen which makes them
very similar to The Watcher in Marvel
Comics now when the situation gets a
little confusing is when the discussion
between the anti-monitor and Metron
delves into the events before the new 52
as we're told during his time on the
chair Metron had witnessed the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths as well as the
subsequent crises that have altered DC's
continuity over the years including the
new 52 proper what this tells us is that
unlike other characters that have
received a reboot with the new 52
Metron & anti-monitor like the Green
Lantern's did not and are fully aware of
reality as it existed before the new 52
was launched furthermore during the
events of convergence it was revealed
that the new 52 universe exists
alongside all of the other universes
that existed prior to the launch of new
52 what this does is point to the fact
that the anti-monitor as we see him here
is the exact same anti-monitor that
existed during the crisis on Infinite
Earths but again because Geoff Johns has
not explicitly come out and said this we
don't know if this is absolutely true or
if this version of the anti-monitor was
rebooted with the new 52 and somehow
gained knowledge of the continuities
prior to DC's reboot
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope that
cleared things up for you guys regarding
the anti-monitor
and I will catch you guys later peace